Now that we can declare tasks,
it's time to start thinking about
the relationships between tasks.
For example,
in a Java build we can't jar up our
library before compiling our sources.
We model these relationships by
task dependencies and order.
We'll discuss three ways to configure
the relationships between tasks.
Depends on, finalize by,
and must run after.
Task A depends on Task B,
if Task A can't do its work without
Task B having done its work.
To take a familiar example,
when you're getting up in the morning,
you can't put on your shoes without
putting on your socks first.
Let's declare and configure some tasks.
So here's our tasks that represent
getting ready in the morning.
We've got put on socks,
just prints a message,
put on shoes also just prints out
that we're putting on our shoes.
The new thing is we've got
this depends on function.
And we just passed the task name
that put on shoes depends on.
In this case, put on socks.
So, let's give put on shoes a try.
And we are running Gradle on quiet mode,
so
that we don't see all
those diagnostic output.
We just see the printed messages.
There we go, when we try to put on our
shoes Gradle realized we can't put on
our shoes without putting on our socks,
so we ran that first.
The next type of task dependency we're
going to talk about is finalized by.
We say task A is finalized by task B.
If every time task A runs,
task B should be run afterwards.
To continue our example,
every time you eat breakfast, you really
should brush your teeth afterwards.
We have those tasks here.
We've got the eat breakfast task,
and the brush your teeth task.
And we note that eat breakfast is
finalized by brush your teeth.
So, let's see what happens
when we try to tell Gradle to
just run the eat breakfast task.
Looks like Gradle It was
keeping us honest and
made us brush our teeth
after we ate breakfast.
The use case for
must run after is slightly less obvious.
Say we have a long running
process that's unlikely to fail,
like deploying some artifact to
a continuous integration server.
And we also have a short running
task that is likely to fail,
like running unit tests.
Those two tasks don't have any
dependency relationship, but
if we're running both we would really
like the unit test to be run before
the integration tests.
To continue our morning routine example,
let's continue showering and
putting on a fragrance like perfume or
cologne.
Putting on a fragrance doesn't require
showering, and showering doesn't
require putting on a fragrance, but
if we're going to both take a shower and
also put on a fragrance,
we should really take the shower first.
Let's create those tasks and
relationship between them.
All right, so we've got our take shower
task, and we've got our put on fragrance
task along with the should
run after take shower.
So now if we go back to Gradle, and we
say hey Gradle, run put on fragrance and
take shower.
Well, let's see what order they run in.
Looks like they run in
the order that makes sense.
First we take a shower,
then we put on the fragrance.
Let's check out a few other things
we can do with task dependencies.
We can depend on multiple tasks, note
this is one of those situations where
you do need to use the equal sign
when you're assigning to a property.
Let's give this one a try.
So since get ready depends on taking
shower, eating breakfast, and
putting on shoes,
looks like we eat breakfast, and
since breakfast is finalized by
brushing your teeth, we do that.
We're going to put on our shoes, but
first we have to put on our socks.
And then we take a shower?Whoops.
Something's not right here.
I think we need one more
ordering constraint.
There's no dependency relationship
between taking a shower and putting on
shoes, but it certainly looks like if
we're going to both take a shower and
put on shoes, we should
probably take the shower first.
Let's change that out.
And there we go.
We say to put on shoes,
you must run after take shower,
and now if we run this again,
looks like we're doing things in
a more sensible order this time.
One more advanced thing we can do is
look at all the tasks in a project and
decide which ones we want to depend on.
Let's make a task called
getEquipped that depends on
every task that starts with putOn.
So here's our get equipped task.
And you'll see it depends on, and
then this is actually a list that was
created by looking at all
the other tasks in the project.
You don't need to understand
how this works right now.
The point is just to show off something
that would be extremely difficult or
impossible to do in other build tools.
Let's give it a try.
And we run get equipped, looks like we
put on a fragrance, we put on our socks,
we put on our shoes.
As always there's more information
to be found on task dependencies
in the course code.
Check it out!